vamos a salud en directo América de
France 24 hoy con el tema que ese
titular alrededor del mundo y es que
alcanzamos los 8.000 millones de
habitantes en el planeta Marina sardiña
nos acompaña con los detalles Marina
Buen día para usted y bueno para dónde
vamos desde aquí ya con este digamos
hitopoblacional Buenos días Ángela sin
duda esto es un éxito y como estamos hoy
hablando va a ser la noticia del día y
es que demuestra que la esta cifra
demuestra una mayor esperanza de vida de
las personas menos muertes maternas
infantiles sistemas de salud cada vez
más eficaces pero pues también muestra
la preocupación debido a la crisis
climática que era lo que veníamos
hablando a los altos índices de
inseguridad alimentaria provocados por
la precisamente emergencia climática los
conflictos o la inflación veamos unas
cifras de los 10 países más poblados del
mundo China India Estados Unidos o
Indonesia lideran este ranking china sin
embargo por primera vez en dos milenios
no será el país más poblado de la Tierra
sino que será superado profundamente por
India y si bien la población mundial
crece hay que recordar que las tasas de
crecimiento se está desacelerando desde
1964 de hecho más del 60% de la
población mundial vive en un país con
bajas tasas de fertilidad esto se deben
parte a que las personas tienen mayores
oportunidades para una mejor educación
trabajos las mujeres retrasan los
embarazos y hay menos personas en edad
de procrear durante la pandemia en 2020
crecieron un 45% menos de niños nacieron
Perdón que en 2015 la tasa de natalidad
en China por ejemplo es mucho más baja
que en Estados Unidos sin embargo en
solo 12 años hemos agregado mil millones
de personas un crecimiento que varía
según la geografía África estuvo un
crecimiento más rápido que el resto con
más del 25%. hacia Oriental sin embargo
con un 4,9%, en los próximos años el
continente con mayor crecimiento será
África Pese a que el más poblado Ángela
se Asia también veamos un gráfico sobre
la esperanza global de vida según la MS
en 2016 la esperanza de vida era de 74,2
años para las mujeres y
69,8 para los hombres Pero esto es algo
que varía también según las regiones
geográficas mientras que Hong Kong tiene
las tasas más altas con casi 88 años de
media para las mujeres Nigeria la
esperanza de vida son los 17 años y aquí
Ángela una vez más influye en factores
pues socioeconómicos y las desigualdades
tan brutales entre el norte y el sur
global Europa tiene una de las
poblaciones más envejecidas del mundo
mientras que América Latina o África
tiene las poblaciones más jóvenes pero
su esperanza de vida es mucho menor
debido como decimos a las inequidades en
Salud Educación o alimentación
aterradora las cifra de esperanza de
vida de las mujeres en Nigeria existen
además Marina temores y preocupaciones
entre aquellos que piensan que viven en
un mundo superpoblado cuéntenos Sí es
que también lo estamos observando estas
cifras y no como personas como números y
esto pues acarrea y genera controversias
por ejemplo antes señalábamos que el
crecimiento poblacional un acelera era
una acelerador para el calentamiento
global sin embargo las dimensiones de
carbono son más atribuibles a los países
más ricos y no aquellos donde las
poblaciones tienen un número más alto de
crecimiento y recordar que las
problemáticas que algunos ven en estas
cifras son motivo no son un motivo per
sede de temor sino que es el modo en el
que interactuamos con el entorno la
naturaleza y los recursos que ya lo
vimos también con la pandemia de 19 como
estas epidemias y enfermedades también
están derivadas de estos desplazamientos
masivos de poblaciones y también de los
vectores que causan estas enfermedades
del hacinamiento en las ciudades de la
falsa de la falta de servicios de
saneamiento higiene Esto es lo que dijo
el jefe de Naciones Unidas
millones de personas están luchando
cientos de millones se enfrentan al
hambre e incluso a la hambruna número
récord están en movimiento en busca de
oportunidades y alivio de la deuda y las
dificultades Las Guerras y los desastres
climáticos A menos que superemos el
enorme Abismo entre los que tienen y los
que no tienen no nos estamos preparando
para un mundo de 8 mil millones de
personas lleno de tensiones y
desconfianza crisis y conflicto
y sobre todo los organismos recuerdan
que debemos educar y garantizar
igualdades a la hora de planificar que
todos los nacimientos sean intencionados
y deseados que las mujeres y niñas
tengan el derecho y la autonomía sobre
sus cuerpos para decir cuando ser madre
o no serlo sí lo hablábamos también más
temprano que
el disminuir la brecha de género
ayudaría muchísimo para controlar los
índices poblacionales Marina vamos a
cambiar de tema porque un nuevo
tratamiento en el efecto salvo la vida
de una menor cuyas dos hermanas habían
fallecido por la misma enfermedad Sí así
es Ángela se trata de ahí lavasir ahora
de 16 meses que al igual que sus dos
semanas que fallecieron Pues padecía
esta enfermedad infantil llamada pompe
infantil grave un trastorno genético muy
raro que afecta a una de cada que a una
persona por cada 100.000 nacimientos la
esperanza de vida de estos menores no
suele superar el año sin embargo por
primera vez los médicos trataron con
éxito al feto mediante una infusión de
una en crucial que le faltaba en su
pequeño cordón umbilical deteniendo este
trastorno hereditario que de otro modo
sería mortal la enfermedad provoca una
carencia de una proteína que degrada el
glucógeno el almacén de azúcar de los
músculos esta sustancias acumula en la
célula en las células musculares y los
menores mueren por un corazón demasiado
grande después de seis sesiones en
diferentes sesiones de seis dosis perdón
hay la nació con el corazón perfecto y
esto Solo se habría tratado
anteriormente en ratones la pompe es una
de las 40 enfermedades raras de depósito
lisosomal significa que faltan proteínas
específicas de los lisosomas los
orgánulos encargados de la digestión
celular Esto es lo que dijo el doctor
que trató ahí la
la idea de la terapia en el útero era en
realidad algo de lo que habíamos hablado
incluso hace unos meses la enfermedad
comienza en el útero la enfermedad
comienza en el feto ya sabes hay
evidencia que el corazón está
involucrado incluso antes de que nazca
el bebé
la innovación aquí no era el fármaco y
no estaba accediendo a la circulación
fetal ambas son cosas factibles o se
hacían todo el tiempo la innovación fue
tratar antes Y tratar mientras aún
estaba en el útero
y Ángela son buenas noticias porque esta
enfermedad pues pueda llenar el camino
hacia tratamientos fetales que alteren
el curso de diversas enfermedades
genéticas graves como la hemofilia o la
atrofia muscular espinal Marina Gracias
a ustedes por la información y sobre
todo por el enfoque para los 8000
millones de habitantes que ya estamos en
la tierra gracias